right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen um
welcome to our planning committee
meeting today i'm sure that with such
lovely weather outside you're really
glad to be in
here um
as you're aware by now we only have one
substantive item to decide upon
and we'll come to that shortly
um but for the benefit of everyone
listening we have a number of procedural
matters to deal with and i will um ask
the uh the clerk to
go through that with us
uh but before then uh have we got any
apologies uh yes thank you chair we have
apologies from councillor d roof we also
have apologies from councillor jay
ridgeway who's been substituted by
councillor n barker thank you chair
[Music]
um have any other apologies from anyone
thank you
um
item two is declarations of interest
um
i have to read this so bear with me
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests
not already on their register of
interests
in any item on the agenda and to
withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
non-received chair thank you very much
uh we're moving on to uh the next part
item three
uh minutes of the last meeting
um
which was held on tuesday the 26th of
april
and are we happy that that is a correct
record and if so can i have a move i
thank you cancer armitage and the
secondary
could i have a seconder
councillor jones thank you
all those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
thank you councillor hancock uh the
motion is carried
right
um that brings us on to the members of
the meeting we have one application
along with the late representations
report on it
um
there are a lot of people who have asked
to speak on this application most of
whom are
objectives to ensure that we can manage
this effectively we will take them in
groups
at the moment most of them are in the
executive meeting room
and have access to the meeting um
electronically at the right time they
will be brought into the meeting in
groups so they can address the committee
and answer any questions
once all of those in the group have done
they will be asked to leave
and so the next group can be brought in
however
they will still be allowed to follow
the meeting again in the executive
meeting room
before we begin i would like to ask the
clerk to explain for the benefit of
members speakers and those watching the
meeting on youtube
how we will deal with the applications
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the application this afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late iceman's agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this
the chair will ask for the groups of
speakers to be brought into the chamber
some of the speakers will address the
meeting through zoom
each of the speakers will have three
minutes to pull forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary in order to clarify any of
the points which they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on the application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate
and ultimately for determination by a
vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
once the group of speakers have
addressed the committee and answered any
questions then they will be asked to
leave the chamber so that the next group
can be brought in
those who've participated by zoom may
continue to view the meeting
and we'll be allowed to participate
further from that point
and as you're aware this meeting is
being live streamed and the recording
will be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you um right we now go on to item
4 which is the application that we're
being asked to look at this afternoon
it is n e d
1 8
0 1 0 0 3 slash
o l
uh and it's at killer marsh it's an
outline application with all matters
except access reserved for further
approval to the erection of 397
dwellings on land
southwest of upper thorpe road killer
marsh
this is major development affecting the
public footpath
um and uh brackets amended information
at the end of that
um so in line with normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any pictures and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
until the end
thank you mr kokum
thank you chair just before we go
through the brief presentation we have
the members who just wish to do a brief
introduction if i may share firstly to
draw members attention to the late
comments report that was issued
yesterday afternoon there is a single
point of clarity chair in that
and it's that the junction referred to
in condition 35 regarding traffic
signaling should actually be referred to
as the bridge street to sheffield road
junction whereas the roundabout referred
to in condition 36 should be the wolf
dro sheffield road junction my apologies
chair that i got that the wrong way
around
before i go through the slides chair as
i said i'd like to ask planning
committee to bear in mind that the vast
majority of the site is allocated for
residential development in the council's
recently adopted local plan
the residual area chair within the
greenbelt is proposed to be used for the
management of surface water runoff and
the indicative layout that we'll come to
in a second shows a series of
attenuation ponds in that area
and members i'm sure will be aware that
engineering works in the greenbelt are
not in appropriate development providing
they preserve openness and don't
conflict with greenbelt purposes
officers chair have considered matters
of design and provision of open space
and concluded these matters can be
controlled adequately at the reserve
matters application stage and as
appropriate conditions are recommended
there's been much discussion about the
impact of the developed on highway
safety chair and members will have noted
that
and the highway authority statutory
consultees conclude that the application
is in principle acceptable subject to
necessary mitigation and conditions and
again that's set out in the report chair
members will note also that flooding has
been raised in representations but
members in that instance will need to
weigh heavily in the balance to commence
the local flood authority who have not
raised any objection to the scheme
infrastructure again chair has and i'm
sure will be raised with members
in this regard the applicant is prepared
to meet all the requests made of them in
respect of increasing and improving
infrastructure save the sole exception
regarding the requested upgrade to the
key cycle network and again that's
mentioned in the officer report
consultees in respect of land
contamination land stability drainage
ecology and archaeology have all raised
no objections subject to necessary
conditions
in respect of ecology some off-site
mitigation the on-site footpath chair
will not be extinguished but will be
incorporated into any new housing layout
so in conclusion chair members will be
aware that the committee will need to
determine the application this afternoon
in accordance with your development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise
officers chair concluded that the
application is in conformity with the
development plan there are no other
material considerations that indicate
otherwise and hence our recommendation
that the application be approved this
afternoon
i'm just asked for alice's help in
respect to the presentation channel just
as a few slides that will go through on
the screen
thank you alice just if you move on a
couple please
thank you this slideshare is in the
application package shows the
application site
in the
yellowish color and the red line is the
district boundary to the south and
southeast you can see on the east side
of the site upper thought road and then
on the left left-hand side of the screen
is green lane reference is made in
report chair to the accesses that were
performed on those two roads
thanks alice
this is the indicative layout that's
been submitted with the application it
is only indicative chair and so um it
will carry at limited weight but in
terms of the issue regarding the land
drainage and the intent attenuation
ponds you can see those on the southern
and south western boundaries of the site
specific references made in the
committee report to those and conditions
as recommended a reference to them and
the area that they cover
and next slide alice
helps in just outlining where the
allocation in the local plan is and
that's kl1 that's the area hashed brown
you can just see the application site
this portion of it to the south and a
small portion to the very southeast of
the application site that lies out and
that lies outside the allocation those
areas remain in greenbelt and again the
report goes into some detail about those
issues
thank you alice
and then just three photographs chair
just as a a memoir to the site visit we
had yesterday these are taken from the
the south of the site
the valley in the foreground of the
slide is the valley where the
attenuation ponds
would generally be located and the site
proper then extends to the north away
from there so you can see where the the
two fields had got horses in that's the
application site was the area in the
immediate foreground of the slide fall
outside the application site
and then just to keep going alice please
the panning ground to the west again the
application site in the middle of the
slide with the houses on green lane in
the
mid distance and then again our list
just panning around again further to the
west
you can then see the west thorpe
industrial estate in the middle of the
trees
and the application site to the right of
there again where you see the road in
the middle right of the photograph that
is the valley that would generally be
taken over by the attenuation ponds and
i think that's the end of the slides
alice thank you
thank you
thank you um thank you council armitage
and i'll repeat that i would now like
the first group of speakers to address
the committee
um i think they're already here aren't
they
they are they are indeed um
can i can i just say that we have around
20 speakers um this afternoon
um
i would
um suggest to them that we don't have
the same argument repeated 20 times
um and that you bring points
um up which you know don't repeat what
has already been said
uh that will aid the process i think
our first speaker um is um
leroy mp who i can see is on zoom
um
welcome to the meeting swirly uh you
have three minutes to speak
and you will be told when uh two and a
half minutes have expired so you can
have your 36 uh 30 seconds to round up
can you confirm that this is your name
and that you understand the process
i do and thank you
thank you you have three minutes
thank you chair and thank you to the
committee for allowing me to uh to come
today i don't usually come to planning
committees i respect the uh reality that
the decisions are made by councillors
quite rightly but this is such an
important issue for the village of
killer marsh and i've received so
significant number of representations
that i wanted to make an exception in
this instance this is an important a
difficult and a controversial
application you're going to hear that
and you can see that from the volume of
of responses and the number of residents
who are with you today i'm sorry that i
can't be there in person i have a
commitments in the house today um
i didn't agree with this being in the uh
local plan in the first place but that
argument has passed and so the question
remains now is as to whether the
inspector who passed the local plan did
so with the right information to put it
in and when we're therefore whether this
planning application should go ahead
and we we all accept that this will have
a significant and substantial impact and
i have the greatest of respect for
officers in terms of the decision uh the
proposed
decision which they have put before you
but i would like to put four things in
front of you which i hope
will allow you to reject this
application the first one is in
paragraph 7.8 to 7.13 and that is about
the number of houses and density
this application exceeds the number of
houses which are in the local plan as
the report states it exceeds the
intentional density and it
exceeds the gross density and i think it
is important that all of those are
acknowledged and my view is that this
proposal is therefore too big for this
piece of land and should be rejected on
that basis i know that the
the applicant believes that the design
review process has mitigated that
potential issue but ultimately it is
your decision and the northeast
arbitrage district council
is about the number of houses and the
density
this and these are exceeded so i would
um humbly suggest to you that you might
reject it on that basis secondly
paragraph 7.1 about the the attenuation
ponds which are in greenbelt there was a
reason that this proposal this applica
that the in the local plan a specific
element of greenbelt was taken out it
wasn't taken out so that further bits of
this application could then be added
into the green belt nearby even if they
weren't physically houses and we have an
application here where the density is
higher than you are than your council
usually accepts and they're allowing
that density 80 seconds remaining
by taking putting attenuation ponds
elsewhere and i would suggest you reject
it on that basis uh i would also uh i
disagree with the highways comments i
wish the highways would take more
account of cumulative impacts on
infrastructure and highways and then
fourthly the suitability of this land
the environmental health comments say
that that can be dealt with in terms of
contamination uh in uh subsequent in the
reserve matters or elsewhere but your
policy sd14 suggests that you should
have confidence about the suitability
rather than i don't think this
application gives it to you i would just
define the chair
thank you
thank you mr rowley all right do any
members have any questions for speaker
nope thank you very much
right we'll move on to um the next
speaker which is um stephen clough
is council club here
oh thank you
you have three minutes
thank you chair thank you committee
um i'm representing as district
councillor and chair of kilomarch parish
council and
these are the reasons why i believe this
should be turned down
the court board dated 14 for the first
22 objects to this application because
the applicant has not demonstrated that
the application is a safe and stable
site in accordance with paragraphs 183
on to 184 of the mppf
the county archaeologist objects to this
application dated 15 for the 21 due to
its non-compliance with the mppf
paragraph 194 and it does not meet the
heritage information requirements this
means losing archaeological features
representing potential medieval and
prehistoric activity on site
derbyshire police design out crime
officers comments dated 28th for the 12
21 negatively on the design flaws and
increase rather than minimizes the
opportunities for crime commenting it is
currently upset unacceptable from a
community safety perspective
the ramblers association response dated
19 for the 12 21 states that the site
plan fails to follow national and local
government policies in respect of
providing access to green space for all
and that the total inadequate design and
access statement does not refer to the
important role that the site plays in
the interconnectivity of the wider
footpath network
derbyshire wildlife trust comments
second of the third 22
that an undated assessment of habitat
loss
using biodiversity metric would help the
help to frame and inform the
compensation scheme such documents have
not been submitted the trust also
comments that the ecological survey data
is now very old and should be updated
the application does not have either an
equality assessment or a site-specific
environmental impact assessment in
respect of the site despite fulfilling
the criteria for both evidence of
contaminated land gas escapes and
immense damage
that will be caused to the environment
in the locality seems to have been
ignored by the developer and officers
this despite the admission and document
dated 30th of the 10th 18th this is a
significant extension to the settlement
of killer marsh there is landscaping
impacts to the highway network and
localized immunity impacts the same
document comments section 1e
that there are not considered to be
overriding concerns as regards
contaminants and pollutants over and
above the development of this scale the
rogers leased environment report on
contamination shows this to be wrong
the development the developer says that
all the roommates all the work can be
remediated their own expert says this is
not the case that's time chair thank you
thank you council club have any members
any questions for him
no
thank you very much
[Music]
and the next speaker is
alex platts
and could i just remind you council
plants that you have three minutes
thank you thank you uh council alex
platt's
representative for kilomot west ward um
at district parish um so
in terms of drainage and flooding um the
application documents refer to drainage
being channeled via coolant to power
brook
um park brook floods badly during every
rain for prolonged periods closing the
road passing over here at its lowest
point at spring hill road this road is
one of the main artillery routes into
and out of killer marsh from the south
would be well
used by occupants of these dwellings
as part of the application
um green lane an access [ __ ] route
from the post site is also subject to
flooding during prolonged heavy rain it
doesn't require a hundred year storm or
a four percent increase in climate
change warming to flood it's happening
now um and in my previous objections
you'll have seen photos around that
and i've personally experienced it i
experienced the floods in november
of 2019
which impacted severely the ability to
actually access my home in that
particular village so it was significant
um
all the rain water emanating from the
dwellings on the proposed site will be
stored above ground detention basins and
below ground storage tanks before being
subsequently diverted to park brook
running a few feet below the dip and
sprinkle road
it's not a major water course it's more
a small stream in normal times
um
a report in 1998 by rgb mining showed
that the company is part of their
efforts clean up remediated improve the
site removed the cool with directing
water from the sign to power broke this
was removed because of a significant
increase in iron concentrations between
the entrance and the eggs of the culvert
rj beans reinstated an open watercourse
department in the belief that this would
significantly improve water quality
downstream of the site it did and there
are local wildlife sites now associated
with barbara
development plans for the site include
the reintroduction of the culvert
emptying into part brook
regular flooding can does and will occur
on spin kill road which is to come by
default to main artillery route albeit
unclassified road
um used as a rat run
from the m1230 for killer marsh
sprinkle road as well at this point is
also a bus route the uprooting the
wildflower meadow at this location will
have a negative effect on soil stability
a probability supported by the royal
botanic gardens at queue they advise
that the complex root structures of
wildflowers provide significant soil
stability as well as providing habitats
and feeding stations for our vitally
important pollinators
the 30 seconds remain the site of
development will increase flooding risk
lowest points of green lane and sprinkle
road which are currently susceptible to
infrequent flooding enclosure although
the periods between flooding are
reducing possibly due to climate change
this flooding is not 100 year event it's
happened three times in the past 18
months and will happen again
development will rob this rural side
most of its ability to absorb excess
water
the rain will no longer fall launch and
be absorbed by open fields significant
rainfall will then be because the top
topography of the air will run onto the
let's time the chair
thank you councilman would you like to
remain in your seat for just a moment
counselor pat
thank you
have any members any questions for
counter plants councillor hancock
thank you chair um just one question
council platter now you've made
reference to the big flooding three
times in the last 18 months
is it typically a multi-time a year
event when these roads are flooding it
is in particularly worse in winter
and coming to sort of hoards and winter
season
and when when the rain falls
it is significant and the current runoff
is not
it's substantial you know we're talking
several
several feet of water in depth um in
historically is one of the picture these
two is a van being almost covered in it
that's happened on more than one
occasion
thank you thank you chair
councillor
thank you i was just
going to ask we've got the late comments
report with some photos of flooding okay
you the one who submitted the photo
yes yes i thought i thought so it's got
your name i just wanted to check so just
for a point of clarification you've
taken several photos of the flooded area
is how close to the
side is this
pretty much on the doorstep of it where
the gate is where you see the water
actually flowing
out and onto the road that is
pretty much opposite the junction
which is where
as looking at the plan is where it's
intended to have some extra sneakers
thank you
thank you councillor hall any other
questions for cancer plants
yesterdays
that was november november 2019 for the
particular one where you see the depth
of the water there
yes
all of those are 2019
that's to demonstrate the absolute
severity of it all
sorry can i remind members to use the
microphones when they're asking
questions thank you
it's all right we could hear you
counsellors
any other questions
[Music]
against
thank you very much indeed thank you
our next speaker is carolyn renick
[Music]
can i remind you uh cancer renee you
have three minutes thank you thank you
councillor carolyn renick the uh county
council member for edmonton killer marsh
cabinet member for infrastructural
environment at douglas county council
thank you for
allowing me to raise my concerns about
the application the number of key
concerns i have about the scheme the
highway's impact of the scheme the
implications of the scheme of the wider
need for infrastructure to support this
application the impacts on the flood
risk and i know it's as a 100-year event
but as alex has just explained this two
or three occasions in the last four
years damage to the ecology area and i'm
also concerned about the lack of detail
and the coal mining risk assessment
however overall um it's this sheer lack
of key information and update
information that concerns me
and the needs for a greater depth of
understanding that would give comfort to
me in the residence of killer marsh for
the ability to challenge some of these
uh
some of these the documents in terms of
the application response
um and therefore um at this point i have
uh no doubt that the application should
be rejected and not enough time to give
examples but just to highlight some of
my key concerns the highest impact of
the scheme and the transfer assessment
suggests proposals will generate about
230 journeys trips during the weekday
peak hours um i think this piece was
wholly inadequate and i'm not sure how
this can identify when the housing types
haven't even been specified yet
the some of this data is based on 2011
census data and 2017 traffic survey data
and does not take account the
significant housing um built around the
boundaries that killer marsh um you have
to appreciate kilimanjaro's uh bounded
round rotherham sheffield and balls over
and there's been some the about 5000
approved houses
over the last few years in this area i
noticed a broker this morning that's
halfway just the road is selling their
houses based on the local amenities in
killer marsh and i'm concerned that
officers at dcc nedcc have perhaps not
accounted for the impact of this
additional trafficking and the
pressure on our highways and
infrastructure and i just wondered why
there's not enough reference to the
local plans of rotherham and um and
bowls over and sheffield in terms of the
housing need
uh this doesn't include the new global
kingdom choice attraction which no doubt
will gather traction after its opening
and i've been raising issues around the
road counts it's becoming the local
council member last june around
eckington and killer marsh
and dcc have acknowledged more
investigation is needed
dcc has raised also a number of
mitigation proposals to be made subject
to condition and 30 seconds remaining
person would like to see more detail um
to
these conditions beforehand um
on behalf of the hundreds of residents
of the objections that i'm aware of and
my own concerns
the lack of detail of mitigation and the
condition set out i until we have an
updated uh
rethink of the statistics and the
assessments provided of the impact on
our local highways i would struggle to
recommend this planning committee
rejects this application and a personal
notice of parenting that's time and
chair thank you
thank you councillor renick um members
have you any questions
come to the hearts on and then
councillor hancock
uh thank you council running um
you made reference to five thousand
areas
five thousand hours being built in the
area um how many of them are in north
east
i i've got the figures actually on this
document but there's five thousand of
which three thousand are in within two
miles of the actual site itself
and so can appreciate the uh significant
impact that will have my worry is the
fact that some of those are actually
majority of those i mean sheffield and
rotherham is that these haven't been
picked up adequately by dcc and nedcc in
terms of the impact so for instance the
half i want to just it's the morrison's
halfway planning development there they
very very cheerfully explain how
wonderful amenities they have in killer
marsh yet we're talking about a
sheffield council scheme here that's
actually uh recommending all the
amenities of their local neighbor in
north east derbyshire i just think
that's not being picked up
thank you
mr hancock
thank you chair um i'm i'm sorry to ask
this council really but the obvious
person to ask it too given your
portfolio at county is why is the
county's report so wrong we're being
told there's no issues and yet we've got
clear evidence that council passes
presented that flooding is a significant
problem um
what what is the reason why we're being
given wrong information here
well i i i sit back colleague does this
the flooding assessment impact but as a
my infrastructure role is more
pre-development so i have had those
conversations and um
for the same reasons when we actually
look to put some of the atkinson uh in
the local plan we actually challenged
some of the dcc's figures around the
number of car journeys and
to be fair the inspector found in our
favor that they were inadequate so as i
could say i've only been imposed since
june and i've been raising that to the
extent i've actually now agreed that we
do more counting of cars in eckinton and
killer marsh and as a as a parent i do
i've got a child and spin kill a child
in atkinson and now at school when i do
the whole circular loop coming through
killer marsh and it's right then the
roads are narrow yeah if you you can
only get one car at a time if if and
this last four weeks as as some of my
colleagues will tell you we've had quite
a significant amount of roadworks and
the impact that's had just getting the
the school traffic around the village
and the backing up um
to me i i can't imagine that being on a
daily basis
any other questions for cancer enoch
thank you
the next speaker is tony lucy
no i don't think is uh in attendance
chair
right okay well we um
we then need to get in the next group of
speakers do we yeah
uh just in terms of that then uh would
members be willing to
now actually go to the executive meeting
room and watch the remainder of the
meeting from there
would you be able to escort them asha
uh thank you for your patience in
waiting in the executive room i hope
you've been able to follow the
proceedings so far
um
so the first speaker in this group that
have just uh joined us is wendy tinley
you go to the table and
the microphone should be switched on i
think if not there should be a red light
on it
and
you have three minutes after two and a
half minutes um the clerk will warn you
that you've only half a minute left
okay off you go we ask you to consider
the archaeological aspect of the west
thought site
land which may have been farmed by our
ancestors from at least the medieval
ages
the gradiometer survey report provided
by wessex archaeology in 2018 suggests
the site contains elements not only for
medieval and post-medieval years but
likely much earlier in the history of
our small town
the clearest example of this is a
rectilinear enclosure with internal
features potentially measuring up to 800
square meters
which the county archaeologist has
informed me as of particular interest
because similar readings have produced
findings that date back to the iron age
the survey also suggests the presence of
the medieval holloway ring ditch
features a medieval strip field system
along with the rigid and furrow
ploughing providing potential evidence
of historic cultivation supporting the
settlement of chinawoods maresque the
name by which kilmosch was identified in
the doomsday survey of 1086 a sure
indication the settlement predates the
norman conquest of 1066.
signing committee members you don't need
me to tell you that the nppf recognises
heritage assets as an irreplaceable
source
paragraph 5.3.2 in the document historic
environment desk-based assessment
published again by wessex archaeology in
2018 provide a list of works as sources
of ground disturbance
disturbance and excavations
paragraph 5.3.3 states that list of
works has the potential to result in the
damage to or loss of any buried
archaeological features which may be
present within their footprints
this could in turn result in a total or
partial loss of significance of these
heritage heritage assets
the next paragraph goes on to state that
any adverse impact to buried
archaeological features would be
permanent and irreversible in nature
continuing with this potential adverse
effect could be reduced through
appropriate
archaeological mitigation
i must emphasize however that the risk
is reduced not eliminated and that loss
would be permanent and irreversible
this site is a potentially important
time capsule that should be protected
till such time when it can be thoroughly
examined
please deny this application thank you
thank you just stay there for a moment
our members have you got any questions
for the speaker
counselor again yeah just um you know
that you mentioned the hollow way
that isn't where the attenuation ponds
are
i don't believe so because i just
noticed there were parallel hedge
hedgerows there already yeah no i don't
believe so
any other questions
thank you very much
our next speaker is claire whitworth
just remind you you have three minutes
intrusion into the countryside and
footpath issues the proposed development
site is currently open countryside with
fields open fields divided by natural
hedgerows providing habitats for a
variety of animals
the site drops 43 meters from the
northeast to the south west making it
clearly visible from station road to
spin kill
the housing line on epithelia road runs
from west to east and is a clear
separation line
the proposed development will be a clear
and obvious intrusion into the
countryside
and will appear visually as narrowing
the gap between killer marsh to stink
hill
the west thorpe business park
lies on the opposite side of green lane
but it cannot be seen at all from
station road at stink hill
it is completely hidden by trees and
shrubbery
a background evidence documents to the
local plan agrees with this stating of
this site that however
that however a development would have
visual impact because of its prominent
setting on the southern edge of killer
marsh
and it sloped downwards towards the
southeast
there are five public footpaths right of
way crossing that site
these give beautiful views towards the
distant this derbyshire hills
to the south and east
the loss of these will be a loss of a
valuable public immunity
these public these footpaths through
sorry these footpaths
through a lovely country area were quite
literally a lifesaver during the two
years of the kobe pandemic it was
particularly important during lockdown
requirements allowing exercise with
social distancing protecting both their
exercise and mental needs these rights
of way allowed people to walk in a quiet
unspoilt country area full of wildlife
wildflowers and where many species were
able to make a safe habitat these fields
are still used daily by many walkers and
dog walkers
the indicative site intends to change
the roots of the public rights of way so
that they pass along streets without any
views of the derbyshire scenery
and the derbyshire design outcrime
officer suggests that the proposed
development designs in opportunities for
crime rather than designing them out
both sets of comments appear to have
been ignored by the developer which
appears
to contravene policy sdc12
these are material planning
considerations 30 seconds remain and i
ask you strongly to deny this
application
[Music]
thank you have any members any questions
for the speaker
no thank you very much
our next speaker is kevin wood
thank you
thank you off again
framework travel plan
i object to this application because of
the very high probability of increased
traffic generation and decreased air
quality
this totally impractical proposal which
i believe contrary contravenes a number
of policies or parts thereof
ss1 sdc12id2
id3 and id4
making this a material planning
consideration
incredible claims in the plan include
its close proximity to the village
center with local facilities and
services and with an acceptable walking
distance of amenities and facilities a
wide range can be reached with a two
kilometer walk
on a map a two kilometer walk for many
doesn't seem immense however
the walk back is all uphill
the majority being one in ten
this would also preclude commuting and
shopping by pedal cycle
there are 44 services or retail
businesses in the center
69 being hair and beauty or fast food
takeaway outlets
so only 31
of the remaining facilities
therefore many services and necessities
need to be sourced outside the village
incurring travel to
adjacent towns or primarily crystal peak
shopping center
the only direct service from site to
crystal peaks is monday to saturday with
only four journeys in each direction all
during the of the off-peak part of the
day
using green lane bus stops
this is totally unsuitable for commuters
and shoppers
the alternative service 80 which has no
bus stops adjacent to the site
plus early and late services monday to
saturday don't go via crystal peaks
meaning no bus service after 7 p.m
serving crystal peaks drake house so
requiring car journeys
the only sunday bus service 80 routes
via south yorkshire townships avoiding
crystal peaks
so to get to crystal peaks involves bus
tram foot
not very easy for some with or without
bulky purchases
officers report paragraph 7.10 says in
relation to maximize housing densities
and particularly in and around town
centres where there is good access to
frequent transport services 30 seconds
it's a total representation
representation and totally wrong
all this forces residents to take the
easier option of car journeys
the design and access statement public
transport section had a number of errors
in the 2018 version and were carried
forward in the 2021 version
i highlighted this to members via letter
so won't repeat it here
if developers can get this so wrong how
can we have faith
thank you
thank you any questions for the speaker
from members
[Music]
thank you thank you
next speaker is paul johnson
thank you chair
kilometers is located in the top right
hand corner of northeast derbyshire as
such it shares borders with sheffield
city rotherham borough bozo district and
chesterfield borough councils and is
very close to basic law this is a unique
situation in northeast derbyshire and
the location has a significant effect
evidence within the local plan shows
that killer marsh has the least amount
of green belt
the least amount of green space the
poorest infrastructure the worst public
transport options and is in the area
with the worst air quality amongst the
main settlements yet it has been
selected to have by far the most housing
allegation
you've heard from council renick about
the 5 000 new homes that are being built
or that's being built
partially built or planned
with planning permission within a few
miles of kilomarsh more than 3000 of
these
are less than three miles from the
killer marsh borders
for example 1800 of them are in a
settlement in clown
which which is called a garden village
and it has um infrastructure it has a
school and it has um an industrial park
next door
um another one like this has more than 2
000 homes a garden village in workshop
sure this will lead to a market
saturation situation if these 400 how
almost 400 are built in kilomarsh
despite sustainability being the golden
thread throughout the planning system
this applica this application is the
epitome of unsustainable development
which may seem strange soon as the
inspectors passed it
it fails in all three aspects of
sustainability as required by policy ss1
and the nppf these being economic social
and environmental
in economic terms this means providing
local jobs that minimize out commuting
the two principal sites are poor
examples on which to build a strategy
where's thorpe site is full with the
last site being developed after 11 years
of inactivity
norwood was given a red designation by
the investigating experts not available
for 10 to 15 years without significant
investment
other sites in killer marsh are judged
to be too old decrepit or full
this means that new residents will have
to commute out of the area by car to
work because of the significant distance
from the facilities of central killer
marsh that you've just heard
the proposed sustainable public
transport plan is unworkable as kevin's
just explained thirty seconds social
aspect means the development would suit
the needs of both current and future
residents uh and you've heard about the
uh removal of the um
five public rights away the
environmental aspect of sustainability
cannot be achieved because of the
immense damage that will be caused to
the wildlife and ecology of the area
including the loss of protected species
and the loss of the wildflower meadow
thank you and if you just remain in
there
members are there any questions for the
speaker
nope thank you very much indeed
i think we now have to make work for the
next group of speakers
thing if um these speakers would like to
return to the executive meeting room so
that the next group can then arrive
thank you
um well it's it's an issue members um we
could do that but obviously there's the
the question about the sheer number of
people within the room i mean we're
trying to actually still follow
reasonably so close to the uh covert
restriction limits which this i think
uh no i don't think we'll be here until
seven o'clock against hancock certainly
i won't
and i'm quite happy that the speakers um
have the facility to
to know what is going on so uh i think
having made these arrangements we'll
stick to them thank you
[ __ ]
uh
[Music]
hi nigel
thank you
right we'll continue uh the next speaker
is kevin bone
mr bone you have three minutes and the
clock will tell you when you have had
two and a half thank you
when you're ready i object to this
application because of the many
hazardous hazard in has
inherent in this specific site
some of which have been identified but
turns potentially others have not yet
been discovered due to limited testing
the coal authority currently objects to
this application
apart from the obvious noise and
disturbance and dangers of disturbing
disturbing the settled land on this site
nearby residents will be at risk of
contaminated homes and gardens
during the construction phase
and when contaminated materials are
removed from the site
they will also be subject to unpleasant
smells and remediation work
when it's undertaken
uh depending and also depends on weather
conditions while it's been removed it
will be impossible to prevent dirt and
dust spread into
currently occupied homes
many of them occupied by young children
the report prepared by
rogers least environmental limited rle
indicates that according to cult
authority records there are six mine
entrances present on the site
some of these definit will definitely
present a constraint to development
but they are not the only potential
hazards on this high high risk mining
site
only one of the six known mine entrances
has been filled and capped
although whether this accords with
today's standards and requirements is
not currently known
with regards to the other five mine
entrances there was no record record of
them being received any treatment
detailed
knowledge of their present condition or
whether one of them is that or where the
one of them is actually located
the report states the risk to proposed
development for recorded mine shafts is
high and will provide a constraint to
development to me in these areas
the rle report states that indication of
potential unrecorded old workings in the
southwest corner of the site it also
shows that
collapsed
unrecorded uh recorded workings within
this scene were encountered during the
extra great excavation of the surface
drift for west oak colorado in the north
of the site
it's 20 seconds remaining it is inferred
that these work workings may
underlie other areas of the site
the report continues um
unrecorded shallow working in this scene
has also likely occurred from the five
recorded mine shafts in the east of the
site
it concludes that the risk of unrecorded
workings at shallow depth impacting on
the development is considered high
rle show that the ground conditions
that's time chair thank you very much
thank you thank you
thank you mr billy if you could just
stay there a moment uh members are there
any questions for mr bone
nope thank you thank you
the next speaker is matt evans
thank you mr edmunds you shouldn't have
three minutes
um the site is situated between two
roads as you know upper thought road and
green lane neither of these roads are
suitable for the size of the development
or the construction thereof
taking up a thought road um the entrance
the proposed entrance is on the crest of
the hill just passed a very sharp bend
from a 50 mile an hour section of road
um where the roads cars were already
travelling too fast on that section a
previous application for a development
of 20 houses on fanny avenue which is on
the opposite side included
an entrance on that same section but it
was deemed too dangerous so that was
that was removed and yet the same
entrance for development of 400 houses
is now proposed
on green lane the entrance is opposite a
long row of terraces where residents are
forced to park on the road essentially
making the road a single carriageway
the road is on a bend there's no clear
line of sight from either end as to
whether there is traffic coming in
either direction until you've started to
make that journey frequent head-to-head
meetings of cars resulting in one or
more having to reverse back out of the
way or hopefully find a space more often
than not there isn't a space
to put an entrance here with 400 plus
cars coming out during rush hour is
absolutely diabolical
there's no option to widen the road on
this section as there's houses at the
top um which will where the car starts
so that would prevent that
routes into killer marsh it's not only
the entrances that are unsuitable but
the rest of killer marsh road network
but from both entrances into the village
there are numerous sections again
blockages due to on-street parking
because of terraced houses straight onto
the road
this causes again head-to-head meetings
of cars cars frequent cars vans mounting
the pavement to get past one another
um
the traffic into and out of the village
along sheffield road has been mentioned
previously but it's an absolute
nightmare during rush hour at constant
tailbacks all the way to halfway and up
towards mother valley
as well it's not uncommon um
all the amenities in the village and as
has been mentioned is not not walkable
it's at the top of a very steep hill if
you haven't been to kilimanjaro if you
haven't seen the site it's ridiculously
steep no one is going from that
development is going to walk into the
town and walk back it's impossible with
kids with shopping
so all of those journeys are going to be
done by car
the transport assessment included as
part of the application is over five
years old it's suggested that only 13 of
traffic from killer marsh goes out
towards sheffield which is frankly
laughable considering crystal peaks
etcetera are all out that way schools
colleges supermarkets
etc it was based on loose census dirt
survey data from 2011 completely vague
completely inaccurate 30 seconds
um
there was a there was some traffic stats
done but again there was no specifics
about it doesn't say how many times it
was surveyed what uh what days of the
week it was done how many times it was
repeated what time of the year again all
very vague and doesn't paint a great
picture
um
about the current state but again five
years old and final point just to say
there's been over 400 objections from
local uh residents not a single one in
support of this
chair
is that it
thank you mr evans if you just say there
a moment members have you got any
questions for the speaker
councillor hancock
thank you chair um just one because
obviously we've seen seen like the green
lane situation and and there's the
comment that about things being widened
but i actually can't see and i'll
apologize because i'm not a resident of
killer marsh i can't really see where
you could widen that to legitimately
make an impact without you having a
bottleneck if you go further down the
road you can't widen that that section
of road it's impossible do you
the road is narrow itself there's
already hedgerows the plan doesn't
include any widening and at the top of
the hill there is uh two semi-detached
houses at the start of the bottleneck so
there's no way
to
you know to even widen the road
sufficiently which would allow clear
access all the way up and on both those
those routes again there were numerous
sections of terraced houses on the road
which even if you get past that bit
you're then stopped again on bends as
well and the long section coming down
from the nags head pub down the hill to
from the high street again as soon as
one goes direct the rescue you're stuck
there
and that's a constant source of cars
mounting curbs
to get past one another
thank you
any other questions mr speaker
thank you thank you
the next speaker is kenneth warns
because we have an audio that is
yes please
yeah my name is kenneth lawrence
i'm a former
calorie winder at my slope culiary
for 15 years and i know the ins and outs
there are five colliery scenes under the
site in question
which are approximately 75 meters deep
only
i get these figures because the shaft
itself was about 75 meters deep
and we could talk to the people in the
pit bottom for the pit top
once west thought closed
the pumping station which was at old
brook
pumping water out seized
thereby flooding all this all these
sites
between
our free
and eckington
that's where the morrison site is there
are three pipes coming out of the ground
which are methane extractors
they've been there for 30 years that's
for one scene
going back to the five seams on the
under the proposed site
is difficult to establish that the depth
same as i said it but it's approximately
75 meters
apparently there's a
geological fault down the center of the
site with a strata unknown
it needs a geological study
it is well known that significant
emissions of methane can still be in all
mine workings
these normally are removed from diffuse
events
of any of these vents being used for
this site
i don't know of any
i think british coal messed up when they
filled the shop
they didn't vent the site at all
so all these five
workings underground
are being flooded forcing the methane up
into the strata
i'm worried
when any
if any
building takes place
when they start digging down
it could release methane
and they could light an apple killer
mask could go up in flames
that's not a joke it's serious
as everyone council to defra regarding
the mine workings
i've looked at all this site and i'm
concerned
it's very much information deferred is
the department of environment food and
rural affairs
effort i've done significant
workings on old mime workings but is the
it is the uncertainty
with five scenes under this site with
possible faults in the strata it needs a
complete geological study of the old
site and not forgetting all the seams
while going under bridge street it all
complicates it
in the past there have been three three
main pits and two others with boundaries
kilometers plus unknown number of bell
pits it affects the old strata and i'm
concerned about all this methane under
our business
thank you
thank you mr
warren members have any questions yes
cancer armitage
thank you chair uh
you obviously have
a great deal of knowledge of the area
uh you mentioned the five pits
uh
how
seems uh how many of
these uh are there of uh what should i
say
bell mines and
unrecorded workings which are already
there it's unknown
what 10 perhaps
i think the last count was 12
and that's throughout the village
um
someone said there were five culinaries
within the village there was no wood
westerlo i'm more
one at chopper never better mow lane and
then plus one over
all workings
and they've all used us the strata under
the village and that's what i'm
concerned with i'm concerned about this
me thing it wants to test to him before
any plans are accepted
right thank you very much
councillor faster
thank you chair uh thank you mr warren
for that
my question is about the response we got
from the coal authority uh which hasn't
changed since it was first
uh submitted in 2018 and it speaks about
and you might have more idea about this
i'm sure it speaks about uh on record
they've been
um
five mine shafts there
and four are being found
and it says
uh that the other has yet to be located
uh but it's likely to be present
uh have you any idea where that that
fifth one is at all sir
um
not really
harry barnes uh the previous mp for
northeast delby she did have
these details that i've not been able to
contact harry for some time
but um
someone said um has anybody been in
touch with detroit or anybody about
these vents that should be taking this
methane out of this land
that's what i'm concerned about because
it's unstable
on that area
it's not very deep if any works carried
out on top i'm worried about that meat
thing coming up some of the same
our queen and eckington there's three
parts still going out to the ground
after 30 years it's still pumping out me
thing
with five seams in that area then it
could be a lot worse
thank you for that thank you chair
any other questions for the speaker
[Music]
thank you mr williams
and i have the next speakers alan
whitaker on the zoo
hello
trying to start
yeah do we have a visual or obviously
just soldier uh no we've got visual i
can give you visual have you got your
camera on mr whitaker
i do
right okay you have uh you have three
minutes um and the clerk will tell you
when you've had two and a half thank you
so off you go
to the northern part of the site is
surrounded by residential dwellings on
three sides
building of a large housing state would
have a significant negative effect on
existing residents excuse me check can
we just hope for a moment is that an
issue
just beginning again sharing the
circumstances
would you like to start again again
okay i'll go now
the northern part of the site is
surrounded by residential dwellings on
three sites the building of a large
housing state would have a significant
negative effect on existing residents
through increased greenhouse emissions
this fact was highlighted in the local
plan which placed a site in the amber
category and states that would engender
a significant increase in greenhouse gas
emissions
the scoping report for sustainability
appraisal of the northeast davis core
strategy
stated this area suffers the worst air
pollution in the district the expansion
of the nearby m1 motorway from six lanes
to eight will surely have made the
situation even worse this development
will only further exacerbate this issue
the institute of air quality management
guidance states that an air quality
assessment should be undertaken if a
development results in increase more
than 500 daily traffic trips the
transport assessment provided
states that there'll be an increase of 2
000 daily trips which is four times this
threshold limit
additionally this development would
exceed the institute of air quality
migrant screening criteria for
assessment of dust impact during the
construction phase due to the very close
proximity of residential dwellings to
the site boundary
a full site-specific air quality
assessment
including detailed dispersion modelling
of traffic impacts should be submitted
in order to assess the potential risk to
existing residents during both the
construction and the operational phases
of the development
this would be another cost of the
developer in addition to the very
significant known remediation costs
which would of course impact upon
viability
neither an air quality assessment nor a
site specific environmental impact
assessment has been provided
the environment impact assessment
regulations state that screening should
be undertaken when a development exceeds
150 dwellings over five hectares
this development is for 397 dwellings
over 17 hectares
initial screening was undertaken by the
planning office in 2018 however since
this assessment various site
investigations have been carried out
which show the actual site conditions to
be very different
six minor engineers have been located
which will need remediation generating
significant dust pollution
significant volumes of highly
contaminated land has been identified
containing carcinogenic compounds and
all this earth will need to be removed
from sight and replaced with sound earth
generating significant dust pollution
some of which will be particularly
hazardous to health
mind gases have been identified and any
works undertaken will disturb and
release these gases which would have
significant detrimental impacts on human
health and the environment
the environmental damage will be immense
with the removal of large wildflower
meadows and ancient headrows and this
will exacerbate the current flood risk
so the two adjacent roads has already
there are 15 resident bird species which
are on the rspb red list of endangered
species which will be severely impacted
by the destruction of their habitat the
installation of bird boxes as a proposed
by the developer is no substitute
air quality and an environmental impact
is a material planning consideration and
i request that you refuse this
application on this and many other
grounds that you've heard that's time
chair
thank you mr whitaker have any members
any questions for mr
no thank you very much
i think we now have the next group of uh
of speakers
stay with us for a moment
ladies and gentlemen
members we now have uh
mr brian
to speak
you'd like to sit at the table mr clamp
um
put the microphone on if it's on it
we'll have a red light in front of it
so if you press the button
okay yes we hugged your red line you
have three minutes and the clock will
warn you when you've had two and a half
thank you off you go
mr chairman committee members i'm brian
trump a resident of killer marsh and
also a member of the kievnock
killermarsh parish council
in my initial objections along with
strained amenities
there is the terrible bus service which
we are currently fighting
to reach a level which will satisfy the
needs of the existing population let
alone an increased one
i mentioned the important the impact on
wildlife
my intention now is to emphasize this
by referring to
global warming and pollution
much publicity is given to this subject
and as such i point out
green areas are the lungs of our planet
and must be preserved and protected to
comply with current legislation
regarding reducing pollution
therefore i request that this planning
application must be rejected denied or
refused but if it is the correct
terminology
to retain and project the green space
thank you very much
thank you mr club any members have any
questions for mr clown
no thank you very much
the next speaker is mr stephen thompson
thank you chair good afternoon everybody
um i do not
profess to have any specific expertise
but i hope members have taken the time
to read my full objections which i did
send by email previously
and i apologize if i repeat stuff that's
already been done but these are my views
policy sd4 and the mppf promote and
require the protection and enhancement
of all sites of biogeo diversity value
together with sites providing habitats
for priority and protected species of
which this site has been recorded as
having many listed as mentioned by other
objectors
the report by access ecology states that
and i quote there is no mitigation for
habitat loss
and the overall loss of the habitat the
breeding birds cannot be mitigated the
biodiversity net gain assessment states
that under the proposed development an
uplifting biodiversity is not currently
achievable for habitats within the site
manor road used to be a light used to be
lined with trees on either side of the
road now there is just one left and if
we want to walk among trees we have to
go across the westthought fields to
enjoy some open acres with views and
trees
are we now to be faced with several
years of noise dust pollution and muddy
roads and a severe reduction in our
desperately needed green space
the northeast derbyshire local plan 2014
to 2034 policy id8 green ways and public
rights of way
states that proposals would result in
the loss of
uh i began proposal proposals that would
result in the loss of or deterioration
in the quality of the existing public
rights of ways will not be permitted
unless equivalent alternative provision
is made
new routes should be direct convenient
and attractive
rather than a pleasant walk across a
natural landscape residents will be
faced with yet more tarmac and pavement
the footpath currently linking up a
thought road to green lane will be
replaced by a tree-lined road
roads are extremely hazardous for
hedgehogs gardens can be very beneficial
to the hogs but only if access between
them is made available
now more than ever before the natural
world is under pressure and in killer
marsh we have precious little green
space to exercise this large development
will have a huge impact on local
amenities
despite the expressed intention that
people from here will walk cycle or use
public transport to visit the village
centre the reality is due to its
location at the top of the steep hill 30
seconds will be more cars on the road
thus contributing to air pollution and
an increase in carbon footprint
thank you
thank you mr thompson have any members
any questions mrs thompson
thank you
the next speaker is chris cosen
you have three minutes mr kevin good
afternoon
firstly let's start off with a question
how many of this committee have actually
read the full application in full
if not it's one man's decision
who in my opinion is misleading this
committee
first of all there are five major shafts
one of which hasn't been found as well
as foot rules bell pits and other
workings
there is also a major fault line running
through this site which when groundworks
take place could fracture and cause the
emission of methane and co2 gas
the five major shafts are being
recommended by surveyors not to be built
upon or within five meters of the shaft
center
the missing shaft at which the area is
known
is currently would have two properties
and a road above it
the technical report states that
two-thirds of this land is unstable
meaning 300 properties would need
stabilizing with piles and grouting
to a minimum depth of 25 meters
this will involve thousands of tons of
concrete of which concrete as we all
know is a major producer of co2 gas
this indirectly clearly opposes the
council's social value commitment
the carbon footprint
another example
is the proposed movement of the public
footpath that runs along the boundary of
the existing properties on up thought
road
now this fourth public footpath has
never ever run through the centre of the
field and has always run along the
boundary of the said dwellings
across to the adjacent footpath meaning
on the perimeter of this development
three existing properties
of gateways
and giving access to this path
the right of access clearly states that
if a public private dwelling has access
to a public footpath for more than 20
years it cannot be moved without the
express permission of the people it
affects
if the council do attempt to move this
public footpath if permission is given
this matter will be going to court
our estates have shown little or no
consideration whatsoever to the existing
residents
eleven years ago i met with a former
employee adam murray who said
that should this development go ahead
they would work with the community to
please both sides
sadly all i see
is how are the states trying to railroad
their plan through
the plan says 330.
397 is nowhere near that figure
but it's ironically the same number i
heard 11 years ago
now in my opinion as a builder with 39
years experience
this site is completely unsuitable for
house building
thank you
thank you mr gerson any questions from
members
no
thank you very much
and now we have mr rod webster
all right so that completes that uh
fourth group could we now bring in the
fifths please
the existing speakers i now leave and go
to the executive meeting room to watch
the remainder of the committee's meeting
thank you
uh
[Music]
uh okay
thank you for your patience and the next
speaker is carol lacy
she here
no
in that case is mr david i apologize if
i pronounce this incorrectly garona
thank you thank you
you have three minutes and you the club
will tell you when uh you've had two and
a
half
and when you're ready all right uh thank
you councillors for letting me speak i
would like to speak about the potential
600 to 800 new pupils that we've taken
up that will be taking up seats already
all
in already over subscribed class
classrooms
i am aware that there is no proviso in
the plans to build any extensions to
these schools or any schools as is
with the very fast rise of autism adhd
and the mental health of many children
in this country
surely council should be cutting
classroom sizes not increasing them
we should be looking at
like one to one teaching not forty to
one
it's impossible for teachers to be
thorough with children's teaching with
the very large capacities in the
classrooms at these schools already
secondly
the doctors
my other concern is you are probably
aware of the situation kill march with
the doctors it is very hard to get an
appointment with a doctor now
so with an extra 400 other adults and a
possibly 800 infants toddlers and
teenagers it will be even harder
the problem that is arising most now is
patients being diagnosed a lot later
than they should
be this
is leading to severe worsen of symptoms
in patients
then then they're having to be referred
to hospital burning without the already
overrun hospitals
third
is
my third concern is crime in kilometers
400 houses is 400 houses to burgle
obviously a possible 600 800 cars to
steal
which we have a lot of cramming
kilometers which is same everywhere i
suppose this will then in turn red flag
the postcodes again
so all kilometers will be paying more
houses and car insurance
then in turn council tax will go for
everyone in killer marsh not just for
the 400 houses
also
climate change
i always thought that council was on the
side of seeing the planet from climate
change but if there's an extra 400 gas
boilers 600 to 800 cars blowing carbon
monoxide all over kilometers
it'll be soon
it will be some time to wear masks for
the fumes not just for the corvette
to build on this land and the
to build on this land and the lungs of
killer marsh will be badly diminished
like uh
sorry
in this case i advise well i would like
30 seconds
in this case we'd like to plead for the
councillors to have common sense even if
it's just for the children's education
uh
that's that is about the end of that i
think
thank you councillors for listening
[Music]
thank you are there any questions from
members uh councillor foster and then
councillor hall
thank you chair uh thank you for that
thank you i asked you a question about
uh you mentioned
doctors yeah earlier so it's a question
around that i've got to be careful our
phrase is because uh gp's uh private
businesses uh but it is a concern of
mine uh i'm a county councillor for
killer marsh yeah yeah although that's
not this is how i've heard of it that
the there is some concern over the local
business the local gp that's what that's
what i've heard uh and whether it's
staying there and some difficulty that
uh
uh there is around it
uh and i read here that we've got the
nhs uh ccg asking for another 190 000
from the 106 payments and that would be
another 993
extra residence to look after them so my
concern is around is the question is do
you know anything as a resident around
this uh
the medical practices and the future
thank you chad well we know that there's
just two full-time doctors here now at
the moment
and it's obviously not enough you know i
mean it's part-time doctors obviously
but it's just the the situation when you
phone up a doctor now with it
it's they refer you to like i'll
example my wife for example that she's
had a bad foot
quite a bit with any operation the
thought's gone bad fair enough chicago
fought down the dodgers for the doctors
and they referred us straight away
to the physio
in four weeks time
but
that that to me is wrong because it
could be anything else you might not be
physically living on if it's muscular it
could be anything something sinister
you should see them say to her then
refer me right it's muscular refereed
but they don't
thank you i was just going to ask about
the schools you talked about the schools
and over subscription
how many schools are they within the
vicinity and well there's no wood
primary c
which
most of them go to i think there is
wales
whale school but
they uh
you know they they just pick and choose
i think whale school but
but
they are
quite a big classroom sizes as well i
think this is it 32 kilo in second
business
and with another 800
possibly 800
children where they're going to work
you're not building an exterior you're
not they're not even building the screen
in the middle of the doctor's surgery as
the counselor says
there's nothing there there's no
infrastructure
what what what oh what i was meaning
within like you talk about wales and
eckington i was meaning within a two
mile walk because we hear about uh uh
school children being encouraged to walk
and not driven
everywhere so
would you say there are sufficient
schools there was a school i wouldn't
say it was sufficient
no not for the not for the size of the
estimators nowhere
if it's possible like i said
if you have one child abusive foreign
thank you any other questions from
members
thank you
thank you very much thank you
um i understand that carol macy who was
the top of my list here is actually
online
yes i'm here
have you got a camera on uh miss and mrs
you'll have to forgive me i'm not very
video
presentable right now
um my point would be
um
the children are being denied further
education
because of the colleges that surround us
in chesterfield and sheffield
they can't get there the buses are
inadequate they are infrequent and the
children either have to go to sixth form
at either westfield um
eckington or wales bar
uh but they are being denied further
education
uh to go to college and i think
considering the two years that they've
had recently of having either no classes
or reduced classes i think it should be
important that any further development
should be further away from killer marsh
because we can't allocate our own
children and my daughter missed out
going to college because she couldn't
get there by bus
and that is the point i like to make i
want this plan to be refused
thank you any questions
mr speaker
thank you very much you may switch your
camera off now if you if you'd like
next speaker is uh bridie mahoney
by zoom balucha
good afternoon um many of the points
that i'd like to make have already been
excellently made
but i would just like to make some
additional points as a resident of west
thor road
essentially
i would implore you to come to this area
before you make a decision and you will
see
that the points that have been made
about traffic and congestion are real
points um we have significant impact
um
for congestion on road safety by the
proposed development
the
exit onto green lane will lead on to
westhalt road which is already a windy
residential road that people play on
children play on people walk down horses
come down to access spoiler lane onto
the trans-pennine trail
the path is very narrow and there is no
scope to extend it there are the if you
meet another person coming along the
path you have to step onto the road to
pass them and that's that's a that's a
frequent occurrence that's daily
um i'd also like to say that the exit
onto upper salt lane
up thought road is very near a bridal
way now this route is commonly used by
equestrians um i use it daily um
it is quite dangerous due to the bend
but with the additional number of cars
coming along that road i'm not sure i
would have the confidence to go along in
and i think many others would find it
dangerous and potentially unusual and
usable
um
the points with regard to infrastructure
have already been been made very well
but i would just like to say that
as a resident of the bottom of west
thought road at the top of green lane i
could not get a bus to anywhere that i
would need to go to it would take far
too long they are very infrequent and
the reality is that i couldn't walk to
killer marsh to go and do my shopping i
would need to take my children and i
couldn't walk back up the hill i'm a
young fit person and i could not walk
back up that hill without with my
shopping and the the thought of going
along the transparent trail alone is is
is just not feasible for
for a young person a young female or a
family
um
i would also say that driving into
killer marsh the
um number of
parking spaces in kilomot itself are
extremely limited so if you were to go
to the supermarket in killer marsh then
you so you know there's already very
limited places to park
the traffic is generally backed up all
the way up um
the main road as well
um and just lastly
it is this area is of real importance to
us in the local area it's not just
grassy agricultural land it's where we
walk our dogs it's where we enjoy the
fresh air the countryside the birds on
nature it's so important to us and i
really hope that you take into
consideration the number of objections
you've made
thank you very much uh any members got
any questions for the speaker
no
thank you
uh and the final speaker in this section
is eva thompson
thank you you have three minutes when
you're ready thank you
uh i'm killer mush parish counsellor
i oppose the development on ecological
grounds as it will have detrimental
effect on ecology of this area and its
surroundings
living near the area i can tell you that
in the area are birds and mammals which
are identified as being the most
threatened and requiring conservation
action under the uk biodiversity action
plan read and unbelieved i personally
saw many of these
and the records from residents say that
there have been spotted 66 different
species of birds and mammals
the applicant is saying blood and birds
in our garden
there are bad boxes on houses but after
three years since the development was
built we saw no bats before we saw them
nearly every evening
also the number of birds dramatically
dropped down
a report from assessed ecology
and knowledge
analogies significant damage to ecology
at the site with habitat loss
disturbance and damage to habitats
fragmentation or isolation of habitats
and disturbance and injury ordered to
fauna
the removal of several sections of
hedgerows all over 30 years old and some
at least 140 years old the report says
that they are of high value and by law
should be protected by hedgerow
regulation 1997.
five are ecologically important
one of them is stretching across the
whole site
these are well functioning but within
the plan will be destroyed and replaced
by a greenway with removal of these
eight mature trees will go
reports also say that about 64
of inc it will be 64 increase of
hedgerows that may be true as a number
but in reality we would need to wait 140
years to have the same quality hedgerows
it also say
changes will represent 44 percent of
habitat loss
exopsycology in direct for 30 seconds
there is no mitigation for habitat loss
they also say
that some effects of development can be
mitigated
but not some of the most important ones
from the ecological perspective
397 properties will bring in average two
cars for each unit plus company cars and
visitors cars
air quality in kilometers is poor to
proximity to that's time chair
thank you thank you are there any
questions mr speaker
thank you very much
i have a question
i'm sorry i'm sorry procedurally we
cancel out that
uh right well we now have um
a sixth group
um these are representing the applicant
um just to explain um
there is only one speaker on the face of
it however
um there are other representatives of
the applicant here who are
willing to reply to any questions we
have of any technical or other nature
there is a precedent for this and it is
permissible so
that's the way uh we will move forward
so can i ask then the um the
representative of the hardwork group
joanne neville
[Music]
as everyone else you have three minutes
good afternoon
i am joanne neville and i'm the regional
head of planning at harworth group
harwith are the applicant for this
scheme and together with three other
landowners we control all of the land
which makes up the site at killer marsh
we have tried to work collaboratively
with the council since 2013 to promote
the site through the planning process
and we secured an allocation on the site
last year this included public
consultation with the local community
and other key stakeholders
in 2018 to support the examination of
the plan we submitted our applica
planning application to help demonstrate
that the site is a deliverable
large-scale housing site capable of
accommodating up to 397 new homes
we have followed the proper planning
process and chosen to work with the
council and wait for the plan to be
adopted and an allocation secured prior
to the application being brought before
committee to seek a decision
we work closely with the council's
offices to show how the new homes can be
accommodated on the site
last summer at the request of the
council we underwent an external design
review of our scheme where a panel of
design experts visited the site made
comments on our scheme and this
culminated in the scheme before you
today
it includes a range of house types and a
density of development that reflects the
local characteristics of the area it
integrates open space and drainage and
creates six hectares of on-site public
open space and two kilometers of
additional pedestrian and cycle
connections
i appreciate that there is still local
opposition to the principle of
development on this site but the council
has had to address its future housing
need and has concluded through its plan
making process that killer marsh is an
appropriate sustainable location for a
development of this scale
we've worked hard with the council and
other council teas to mitigate the
impacts of the development and
demonstrate that there are no
outstanding technical challenges to the
delivery of the site
this is evidenced in the committee
report with no objections from the
council's statutory and technical
council tease
throughout the examination of the plan
we sought to ensure that our scheme was
policy compliant and today we're
delivering what we said we would in a
policy compliant allocated housing site
delivering 20 affordable housing and
contributions towards education health
and sport provision
the officers have provided a
comprehensive report which addresses in
detail all the material considerations
and recommends that planning permission
be granted
if the application is successful today
30 seconds we will progress marketing
the site for sale with a full technical
pack and we would expect to conclude a
sale by the end of the year this means
that a full range of house types
including affordable housing would
commence delivery during 2023
thank you for listening
thank you very much
not have any members any questions
councillor hancock
thank you chair um obviously you've
heard a lot of the things that have been
stated through the afternoon and we've
got photographic evidence of some of
them um one um there's several i'm not
going to hog the whole thing i'm sure
people got questions to ask but one of
the key things that strikes me is for a
development of the sites that you're
proposing the access from the other
roads is just totally insufficient
excuse me it's totally insufficient
these roads aren't built for that kind
of purpose
and one of the things i'm really
struggling to get my head around
is how
you're going to get the
let's call it 400 because ultimately
that's what it is how are you going to
get the traffic for 400 houses down
these narrow country roads which is
effectively what they are and
without that i don't see how how the the
development is sustainable at all
well our application was underpinned by
a robust transport assessment which did
actually assess 400 homes
and we've heard today about concerns
about traffic and capacity
we're proposing three access points one
from green lane and two on upper thought
road those points have all been
determined based on speed surveys so
that visibility is appropriate
following public consultation comments
we've extended the width of the green
lane access so that the highway will
become seven meters wide that allows for
people to park down the side
um our assessments were based on 2017
trip generations which was agreed with
the local highway authority
um that is underpinned by dft
guidance that says that's appropriate to
do so and that takes into account
all the developments that are happening
in the locality so it picks up comments
that people have made about schemes in
bolsova and rotherham for example um if
if we looked at it today post covid
flows different to probably what you
would look at in 2017 because the am and
the pmp were true peaks whereas now it's
a spread
so so um and the local highway authority
agree with everything and support the
application subject conditions
thank you chair um i wonder if you could
just comment on on this one for me the
it says the shot the site should be
at a capacity of 330 that's the starting
point i guess
but you've gone 397. if you'd done the
extra 67 less would you've been able to
put the attenuation ponds on that site
and not into green belt
i think
in in our view the 330 is the starting
point for housing number the national
planning policy says it's it's a minimum
they're not maximum figures and your own
local plan talks about density of
development that's appropriate so we've
been through an external design review
as well to give some comfort that the
density whilst it's higher than the
figure in the local plan i think with
two dwellings a hectare higher it's
still appropriate given the mix and the
characteristics of the area design
review actually commented that to the
north of the site we could possibly be a
bit more dense with density reducing to
the south
and and in terms of putting the
balancing ponds
in the green belt again this is being
tested through national policy and case
law um national policy is guides that um
it's
appropriate to put drainage basins in
the green belt it's been tested at
appeal as well the drainage basins work
in the green belt the site has now extra
allocated housing sites so in our view
the 397 is making efficient and good use
of a very sustainable site
thanks dan thanks for letting me know
that it's been tested at appeal
against the foster
thank you chair thank you for that uh my
question's around uh 106 monies and um
what's been mentioned by uh highways and
what they think would be suitable
measures uh
for addressing the traffic concerns and
if we look at uh what's
in in our page 18 we've got at the
bottom of there
it says um about introducing these
different measures including uh not just
the travel plan but uh altering uh
although we've got it mixed up on our
fingers altering the uh
the roundabout and also introducing uh
traffic signals
so they said those are the measures now
when you look at what normally pays for
those and you'll be more aware of this
than i am normally that that sort of
infrastructure is because what we don't
have uh in our area
what's what's the agreement we don't
have uh sale
sorry sale that's it
we don't have that so and anything would
have to come out of the one or six
monies and that's what they've said now
my concern is when you look at the one
or six months that we've got at the back
on page 35 it all adds up to around
about 670 000
yeah so that's the 106 monies which goes
health educational libraries and the
rest is sports and travel plan
monitoring costs now
there's nothing there which is currently
being
pushed towards or suggested that pays
for this these infrastructure changes so
these traffic lights the change to uh
the roundabouts possible road widening
really big infrastructure things that
will affect uh killer marsh my concern
is who's paying for this for this to be
sustainable it's who's paying for it now
for me it looks like the taxpayer is
paying for it
your company
rightly so unlike it should be should be
or your company you represent should be
making profits absolutely completely
with that
however it's who pays for this which
makes which makes it it begs the
question is it sustainable
when all these things need doing for you
to be able to build these three nine
seven or three third time so it's about
my questions about sustainability give
me a view on that who pays for all these
that are being suggested thank you
so we've got a full suite of section 106
so 20 affordable contributions towards
education health sport libraries um i
think travel monitoring and then in the
conditions we'll accept a condition
about the bridge street sheffield road
junction we will have to put that in and
we will put that in with the highway
authority under a section 278 or section
38 agreement so we will fund that but it
will be a separate agreement like a 106
that just sits in its back the condition
that is there to make sure it goes in
but we will pay for that similarly with
the white lining changes on the
roundabout of the walford road sheffield
road junction we will pay for that that
will be done under section 278 section
38 and similarly with the green road
green lane widening to seven meters it's
in our gift to do that because it's
within our land ownership but we will
extend the highway and we will pay for
that as well so section 38 and section
278
thank you for that thank
you any further questions from members
thank you very much
right we now move to the next section of
the meeting where members will now have
the opportunity to put questions to
officers about the application
can i just say that
i would like to keep this part of the
meeting or our proceedings focused on
getting clarity
about any points you are not sure of
once we've done that we can then have
our own discussion about the application
itself based on what we have heard and
we have
read um i would be grateful um if you
could not move any motions in this part
of the meeting at this stage
let's wait until we've had all had a
chance uh to make our assessment with
our questions to offices
so any questions to officers
i'll start at the far end with
councillor liggett
thank you i've got a couple of questions
the first one
two officers is
why they haven't requested an eia
as uh members of her chair an assessment
was done on that following submission of
the application and it was deemed that
an eia wasn't required in this case and
that determination was made by the
council and to the applicants so no way
no eia was required it wasn't deemed
necessary for this scale of development
i find that slightly worrying adrian
especially with mineshafts and methane
and
hedgerows and wildlife
which there is a formal process that was
gone through by the council by council
officers that assessment was made based
on the criteria set out and the relevant
regulations no determination made at
that point
thank you my next question is um
i think it's probably a new term that
officers are probably not even
conversant of yet but natural england
water neutrality
uh apparently within the next 20 years
we're going to have severe water
shortages in this clean drinking water
um equivalent to a lady of hours worth
of water per week more needed in this
country
and i just wondered if you can cast this
as
a feasible development
can you guarantee that it's not going to
reduce the water supply
to this local area
sure i'm not in a position to to make
comment on that i don't know the
circumstances the case nor the issues
that
council ligatures has referred to as
officers we've sought
in our report chair to address as we see
it and reflect on all the the relevant
material matters
and
predominant of those is the allocation
of the site sharing your local plan for
residential development so that's the
starting point that
we had and the adoption of the plan um
about six months ago so that's the basis
of our assessment and
all the matters surrounding this site
and the issues that has linked to others
um and we've heard discuss this
afternoon will have been taken into
account the inspector made her decision
on the allocation but in specific
reference to that question chair it's
not an issue that's been raised in this
circumstance during representations to
us nor by any of the statutory
consultants in respect of water
provision indeed the water provider has
not raised any objections subject to the
protection of their sewer that
i believe crosses the site so that's the
only comment we've had back from the the
statutory delivery
cancer elliot
thank you chair
adrian i wonder if you could just um
let me know about this one air quality
i'm talking about air quality you've got
a motorway that's been put down to four
lanes and slowed down 50 mile an hour
for traveling through to
prevent or to help the air quality
yet we're pushing for
probably or potentially eight or 800 or
more movements today with vehicles
on on this new thing not so many miles
away from that motorway
can you comment on that one from me
please and at 722 a we're talking about
a swept path auto track
where the highway authority uh differ
and the applicant differs to what size
vehicle has been used to test the paths
for larger vehicles
the applicant obviously would consider
the swept path acceptable
but again it remains a as a
final discussion and and noted that no
objections been raised by our own
council street scene team could you
comment on those two please
it's taking the the first point first
chair the issue of air quality
has been assessed by the environment
environmental health officer and in
their response to us at 7.31 in the
office report comments made on that
chair and particularly i'd ask members
to note that the mppf and its advice
says that the matter of air quality is
properly addressed at the plan making
stage so again that would be a being an
issue that was properly addressed at the
plan making stage by the inspector in um
in the local plan inquiry just on the
the second element chair the issue of
the
specific swept path analysis
hasn't been finalized and therefore it's
reserved in the condition
forgive me i don't know the
specific number but it's reserved both
in
condition
to be required to meet the
relevant
it's the waste vehicle size in effect
that's dictating the sweat path analysis
so that will need to be
addressed when the actual delivery of
the roads through the reserve matter
stage
is
submitted and then that can also be
conditioned and retained as you've heard
this afternoon by a specific agreement
with the highway authority under not
sure if it's section 38 or 278 but in
terms of the delivery of the new road
network so as officers we don't believe
that's a technical issue why you
couldn't grant permission this afternoon
for this scheme you retain control over
that it's just a look at 731 adrian and
i had starred it when i was reading it
last night at 7-3-1 the aho really how
can they say that it's improving air
quality having another 800 movements a
day i don't get that one
i'm not here to say that um
the delivery event will necessarily
improve air quality i i'm not able to
say that all i'm able to say is that the
advice we have
is that air quality is not considered
overriding by our advisor on that and
indeed was
your advice in the mppf is that should
have been properly addressed at the plan
making stage so not an issue that should
derail you for making a decision on the
application this afternoon okay thank
you adrian
uh any more questions yes
councillor foster and then councillor
armitage
thank you mr kirkum for that uh first
question i've got is about uh dcc
and their response and i'm looking at
page 18
um
we've got at the bottom of the clarity
sort about the level of development
proposed it's a bit worried
that that's there from dtc
i don't know if that means they're not
sure how many houses are going to be
built there or so a bit of clarity on
that um cloudy sort of the level of
development proposed that's from
from highways
uh also confirmation that the impact on
the 618 sheffield world midi roundabout
is not significant
so they're wanting
confirmation from someone else
um so that's a concern that that
paragraph there
and probably last question on on
highways is about the traffic assessment
uh if we look at the accompanying
documents um
well online vr the letter from dcc 14th
of jan and 11th of may they both refer
to a traffic a transport assessment so
my question is there's no reference
there to who's done the track uh
transport system that i could find it uh
so that's my first question you've got
in highways
thank you
just on those chair i'm not here to um
speak for the for the county council in
terms of the level of development
proposing there
uh seemingly an inability to understand
that but first of all i'm satisfied that
highway authority are aware of the level
of development that's proposed
and that their assessment has been based
on the submission chair for the 397
dwellings and the transport assessment
that's been submitted
they have i'm
personally aware that they've sought
advice from colleagues or or our
contacted sort of advice from colleagues
on the various elements and that is
what's led to the delivery of the
recommended conditions as per the
updates pack chair so in short the
highway authority have confirmed that
the no objection to the scheme subject
to the various conditions just in terms
of the
mini roundabout i think it's the one
that's referred to that
we got wrong as officers in our
recommended conditions it's the one at
the junction of walford road and
sheffield road and i apologize for that
chair but there is some
relining of that roundabout just to make
sure that roundabout is accommodating it
can accommodate the level of traffic and
there isn't a small element of
engineering works that would accompany
that but fundamentally that roundabout
will in conjunction with the traffic
signaling that you've heard and also
talked about this afternoon that would
address any concerns that the highway
authority has with regards to road
impacts and finally and as foster
mentioned the issue of the transport
assessment that's been submitted by the
applicant and has been
assessed and
evaluated by the highway authority in
their responses to us and
yes the the final elements have only in
the past few days been addressed but i
have had
significant correspondence with the
highway authority over the past few days
to finalize the wording of the
conditions
and i can advise members that subject to
those conditions and the mitigation that
you've heard the highway authority are
satisfied from their point of view that
the scheme is unacceptable
thank you that mr come here i've got
other questions but i'm not just
it does you just concern me though when
you look at the statements they're in
there clarity sorts the level they'll
not propose if it's
if it's being sorted you know anyway
i'll move on um
the other one is about on page 1718 uh
the archaeology um
and
it says at the bottom of page 17 dtc
archaeology the position remains as it
was in 2018 the application does not
meet the heritage information
requirement uh paragraph 194 and ppf
uh so could we have a bit of a
i'm sure it's been sorted since and it's
probably
in uh the late comments although about
this the late comments are quite large
and because i've been here this is the
first time i've seen them sure like many
others i've had a chance to read through
these so if it's in there please excuse
me uh but just a bit of a an explanation
on that that it does not meet the
heritage information requirement uh as
per paragraph 194 which i got somewhere
yeah again just on that chair it's a
matter that's been addressed later on in
the day again in the past few days and
it's um
it's the first comment in the late
updates comment with regards to the
final comments of the dc archaeologist
and the conditions that are recommended
relate
believe to
condition 19 that's recommended again in
the pack that does require
the
delivery of the
written scheme of investigation to
follow the submission made in march 2020
and there's an element of that that
needs to be carried out in addition
um
earlier rather than later just to
address that final element but the dc
archaeologist is happy that that can be
dealt with through a submitted written
scheme of investigation as i say that's
condition 19 of the pack
thank you that one last question chair
um oh i can give way to councillor if
you like
i know you will finish off council
faster and then it's canceled armitage
thank you chair um a question uh i
mentioned earlier you might have heard
me speak to a mr warns earlier when
asked him the question about uh the call
authority
uh when we look at the documents we've
got on file
i'm sure it's changed in the last couple
of days
we mentioned we talk about the six
recorded mine entries um
five of which are shafts uh four have
been found and there's a
there's a fifth one that can't be found
but it says in the the mining report
which is still
uh from the documents online this is
still valid
uh and it's yet to be located and likely
to be present uh that's what's on page
two
of the cool authority uh eighth eighth
of november 2018
they then updated it when we asked for
an update from
them somewhere but it's been updated i
think december
yeah 21st december uh 2021 have you got
any news on that please
that's still as um you you read it chair
the
recommended condition
number five addresses that and the coal
authority are satisfied with a scheme of
intrusive site investigations to locate
that mine entry and then implement any
mitigation needed to address it and the
other elements that are set out in the
submitted report the coal authority are
recommending again subject to that
condition
that again that's not a matter that
would preclude you granting consent for
the scheme this afternoon
chair cancer armitage
thank you chair
uh
could you tell me uh adrian
uh
do we really need all these houses to
bring
us up to the required number
uh
bearing in mind that
if we go around the region the uh our
area
there are developments springing up all
over the place and
have we got our required quota of houses
for this area
or do are we going in excess of what we
need
the site chair as an issue i've
mentioned a few times already the site
is allocated in your recently adopted
local plan for residential development
so
what the council is saying in that
allocation is that
the
principle of residential development on
the site is acceptable
and you'll have seen and you've heard
this afternoon that an approximate level
of dwellings this site in your local
plan is 3 30 and that's to meet the
minimum levels of housing needs that's
the 6600 in the local plan so that
element of this site is to meet that
requirement however as with all these
things the numbers that are set out and
within the local plan are not minimum
numbers
and there's no reason why subject to all
the other considerations and
assessment of those to reserve matters
stage that with a suitable design 397
houses couldn't be accommodated on the
site subject to those criteria so in
terms of meeting your minimum
requirements
this site has been allocated to provide
330 dwellings of that
but there's no reason as we set out in
the report there's no reason why a
larger number couldn't be accommodated
particularly as the submissions made and
the comments made on them by the
statutory council teas have assessed
that in their opinion subject to
condition
that there's no reason why that large
number couldn't be accommodated here
so in actual fact
the
397
is uh what shall i say
it could easily be uh
you could put 500 houses on
if you thought to share that that was an
appropriate number they could be
accommodated on the site acceptably in
terms of their design and in terms of
all the other elements that you've heard
discussed this afternoon all the
technical elements yes that would be
appropriate if you thought that was an
acceptable number the submissions been
made predicated on 397
and the submissions made have sought to
evaluate that and show the acceptability
of that number on this site which is why
it's made in those terms
council elliot
thank you chair hey jim can you just
tell me what you think of this one as
well drainage and flood risk on page 31
733
sites located outside flood zone two and
three so not in an area liable to flood
uh i just refer you to the one of the
speakers um late comment photos 20 page
20 21 22 23 um not liable to flood
i don't know the circumstances of those
photographs yeah they've been submitted
in in in terms of providing members with
all the full information we've put them
in the pack but i i can't tell you why
in what circumstances that
situation
was
delivered or how it happened i don't
know about that
all i can advise you again is that the
issue of what's in the photographs is an
existing situation so that's maybe
happening now for whatever reason
but again we often have the discussion
at committee about
a future development should properly
address its own
surface water runoff and that's what in
this instance the submissions have shown
and the provision of the attenuation
ponds where revised would deliver so the
housing
on the side should not make any existing
situation worse in fact they may
regulate runoff better than the existing
we as a planning committee have this
exact same thing on clay lane and uh
still been dealing with it and the
attenuation puns were put in as a good
gesture afterwards and we still don't
know whether that's going to do what it
should do
and this says this is
the surface water will be primarily to
be dealt with by the attenuation ponds
what else is suggested and if this this
is only primarily dealt with
the overall drainage strategy chair has
been shown to accommodate the or
um the modelling has been shown to
accommodate what would be the runoff of
the site there would be various other
mechanisms these areas open space that
are left on the site that would of
course take some the surface wood
through soak away as well but in terms
of the runoff that would come off roofs
and hard surfacing there is a different
runoff rate
you know this i've no need to tell you
this
but but just in terms of um i know we're
talking about other sites but again
members will have heard who says before
you need to consider this application on
its merits and again the advice we have
from the technical consulting the local
flood authority is that the scheme can
accommodate its surface water without
detriment
are there any other questions for
officers
[Music]
uh counselor jones
yeah my main concerns about the emission
of gas is
and the fact that we do not know where
this other mine shaft is
now
my house is built on an area where
there's a lot of mining
and when we look at our deeds pack
there's loads of information from the
national coal board
and i wonder if in their archives is
answers to where these actually seems
are and these minds
and shouldn't we really be investigating
it more just to make sure that everybody
involved is safe including the people of
kilimanjaro
[Music]
yeah that's exactly what the coal
authority have recommended in their
condition
and
the recommended condition of the coal
authority is as recommended by officers
so that that safeguard can be provided
chairs so that the mine shaft that
hasn't yet been found will be found in
any remediation of that
and the rest of the site can be
accommodated safely so so again the
advice we're getting from the statutory
council team in this instance is
saying that with that condition they are
satisfied that any residual
land stability can be addressed properly
in the way that
has been suggested
any other questions for officers
[Music]
council elliot thank you chad adrian
could you one of the uh previous
speakers i know we've had a lot of them
mentioned about contaminants could you
appraise the committee of what's
happening with that once they start
scraping the ground please
again share the comments of the
environmental health officer has
addressed that particular point and
there are again recommended conditions
that would address any residual land
contamination and they're again set out
in the report so again that would be
safeguarded as per the
the coal issues the residual and land
stability issues thank you adrian
ask the foster
thank you chair uh mr kirkland my
concerns uh
are still around the the amount of
houses that are on there uh the 397 as
as opposed to put forward in the local
plan
uh the 330 and when i read page 27 under
7.1 of the pack
uh it says that i'll let people catch up
if they want to follow what i'm saying
uh the allocated local plan yield of 350
is based on a starting calculation
absolutely true but a flexible approach
is advocated in the local plan
now it doesn't say that that it's
advocating on the local plan page 142
8.58 it says it supports it which is for
me it's slightly different it's a tender
phrase and these these can all be
interpreted but that's what we're here
to do interpret these words and
interpret these policies and provide
different ways to different uh different
policies so for me i'm concerned about
that that it's mentioned there that it's
advocated as opposed to support
with the characteristics of the site and
surrounding area at determining the
appropriate density it's actually the
most appropriate density so i've got
concerns in how it's been put forward
and it is it's not a statement it's at
the question chair uh and i i'd happily
hear that the answer
it also mentions about where there's
good access to frequent public transport
services as per policy sdc 12
and we've heard from many people already
many people that know killer marsh that
you you don't have uh good access to
frequent public transport services at
all
uh so so that's my concern around the
the 330 being pushed over to um
to 397. it's also mentioned in the uh
the mppf2
uh
and this is what we're talking about
efficient use of land uh it's not
necessarily what's efficient use of land
it's what's appropriate which for me is
much more important and if we look at
yes the foster we're getting into a bit
of debate here can you can you have some
clarity about i'll limit to that
well i was going to suggest that you you
could tell us what your questions were
for the benefits of mr kirkham i'd like
a comment from mr kirkum on that it's
about the 330 to 397.
the
local plan chair again i come back to
this um
headline point i guess that the
local plan has allocated the site for
residential development and
the number set out in the local plan is
an approximate number then as as
councillor foster says there's other
considerations in the plan and
if
the the wording that i've put in the
report um is not exactly that in the
local plan chair i
apologize but certainly the way that
you've heard and members will have read
the report and you've heard council of
foster the the issue to my mind is still
the same that 330 isn't a fixed number
and that it needs to be then taken a
step further as to what
the site or a site can accommodate
appropriately and that is as you've
heard council foster say that's based on
the specifics of the site and how the
site may accommodate dwellings
so the the density is the starting point
that isn't the finishing point that's
the um wording of the the local plan so
you need to make that
assessment in this instance
as you've heard the
site has been subject to consideration
by a design review panel
they didn't come forward with any
suggestion that 397 wouldn't be
appropriately accommodated and as as
counselor foster says the efficient use
of sites is advocated
by words but advocated by government to
secure
a good use of of land and in this case
the conditions that are proposed would
safeguard
levels of open space on the site that
would at least match what's required in
the local plan
and so again from an office point of
view
can't see any good reason why 397
dwellings couldn't be accommodated
appropriately on the site that would be
subject to your consideration if
appropriate of any reserve matters
application and how that would be
delivered just in terms of the issue of
sustainability
the local plan
is predicated on producing sustainable
development or providing sustainable
development and that would have been one
of the salient considerations
in the
consideration of the inspector at the
inquiry and also then in the adoption of
the plan by the council itself so in
terms of the issue of sustainability
killer marsh is one of the most
sustainable settlements in the districts
one of the four most sustainable
settlements in the district it has
levels of amenity and services that
aren't
replicated in the smaller villages and
settlements therefore
your plan was based on that
headline assessment that
delivery of new development would be
concentrated on those four settlements
so i would
ask members to bear that in mind in
making a decision this afternoon and
that killer marsh
is one of those four settlements so
should provide sustainable development
and that's been evidenced by the
delivery of this site as one of your
allocations in the local plan
thank you any other questions
thank you mr kirkham
um
we now come to the debate um when
members have the opportunity to uh give
a view of what they have heard what they
have seen
um
before we do that though um i'd just
like the clark to remind us
um
about emotions
um
as i say this is the debate motions come
later but i will ask the clerk to
explain
yes thank you chair
please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
the vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
now in terms of the timing of motions
they should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
and will then invite motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair
thank you all right i'm now opening the
floor for debate cancer armitage
thank you chair this is a difficult one
we've looked at everything on it
there are loads of
reasons uh
for turning it down
and
we've got things like
methane gas
there are a number of
mine shafts and there are also
small
ones that are not recorded
the grand ground is
considered generally unstable
uh
we've got the loss
of the landscape
uh
i mean it's the impact of on the
landscape the ground rises up and as far
as i can see this development will stick
out like a sore thumb you better see it
from miles around
we've also got
the housing density
with
you know that's bigger than uh we're
going to
originally have
and then something that uh
linked to the impact on the landscape
uh and the floor reformer we've got the
impact on the uh listed buildings which
uh are all around uh the area there's
uh i think three different lots
uh and then we've got the loss of the
five public footpaths all right so we're
going to re-route them and all the rest
of it
and then we've got the fact that uh
we've got ancient uh hedges and it
doesn't matter what happens uh with
those
once they're ripped out they've gone
they're gone for good
and they'll take probably
100 years for them to be reformed and
for the actual flora and fauna to be
replaced and here we are saying oh well
let's plant some trees and here we are
ripping them all out and to me
i just can't go along with this plan
whatsoever
thank you cancer hermitage councillor
foster thank you chair uh my concerns
are the one we just discussed and i
won't go over the points again uh my
concerns are uh to the committee is that
it exceeds the figure in the local plan
and they've given the reasons why
um we don't we don't have to go to 397
we can stick to 3 13 we can do that it's
in our local plan
uh that's up to us as a committee uh
number two the attention pond in the
green belt i don't believe this meets
the exceptional circumstances set out in
the local plan at all or paragraph 147
of the mppf
developed not to be approved except in
very special circumstances slightly
different
i also don't agree um that uh this is
it's more difficult when it comes to the
highways because of uh all the things
that have been discussed and mentioned
but my view
um
you know it's a very very busy place
already killer marsh the roads are
packed all the time um
you know i've got little faith in that
uh in that transport uh report that
transport assessment very little faith
in that
uh so for me uh the only place we can go
on this when we look at what policies we
could possibly look at is policy id3
sustainable travel uh the only way is to
say it is uh the cumulative impact would
be severe that's the only place we've
got and i'm sure we'll receive some
advice on that that's where i i think it
starts it would be severe we know the uh
anybody that travels through kilimanjaro
unfortunately i do travel from kilmarsh
to work
um
for killing but unfortunately uh
but yeah i do travel to that i know how
busy it is uh through that it's packed
and this is going to be uh when we look
at the number of residents which are
going to be living there we're looking
at six 700 uh cars it's going to be much
worse so for me it is uh sustainable
travel and it is number four um
and the last one
and my last concern is uh
that uh which is the mining one which
we've discussed a few times now and it's
about these mine shafts which we don't
know where they are that they are that
they are there uh and we're not sure i'm
not sure about the gas
that i don't know uh because i'm not an
expert in that but from what i know
about the mine shafts and the
instability of the land uh i'm happy to
say that uh
we shouldn't be approving this uh based
on local plant policy sd
14
where development proposals will not be
permitted unless it can be demonstrated
that any land potentially affected by
contamination or instability so
uh
so it's potentially affected so those
are my concerns to the committee those
four
thank you chair
thank you councillor foster
council hancock
thank you chair i i agree with both bill
and i'm marking a lot of what's been
said here um
i respect totally what adrian's saying
about the the um we've got conditions to
address multiple things but i'm actually
struggling to see how this development
at all is sustainable at any level even
the 330.
um
i i take fully on board what carolyn
said earlier when uh as environment um
environment portfolio at holden
derbyshire county council
that uh we can't give too much credence
to the reports that have come from there
and we've got photographic evidence
which shows us that the roads which will
lead into this estate
are too narrow
we've got evidence of flooding which um
which one council actually told us
happens a couple of times a year
so irrespective of of
what whether the development itself
addresses these problems or what it
brings
these problems already exist and
actually make access to the site
um
very difficult if not totally impossible
at certain times of the year
um
as mark says there's a huge question
mark over over this whole contamination
instability
issue and could any of us sit here in
good conscience and allow people to move
into houses that's on on land
that's that's dodgy to start with
i don't drive so i know exactly what
killer marsha's sustainable travels like
on on public transport when we were
having meetings up there it was
atrocious
um so so
it falls down completely on id3 um but
as i say for me that none of the develop
i i actually look from from the visuals
that we've got and yes i can understand
where they're kind of coming and saying
yes this space could accommodate
the 397 and i'm sure it could and with a
great designer yes it can the reality is
killer marsh can't sustain that and and
even if you were to
that that plot of land the size of land
is fine yes it would work but where it
is doesn't and none of it to me is
sustainable to meet our own local plan
thank you councillor hancock councillor
hartson
thank you chair uh yeah in fact uh
what council of foster mentioned earlier
that was top of my list id3
um sustainable travel i think it's a
real problem i thought i think those
roads are too narrow if i'm honest
um
to take the volume of traffic that will
be traveling from that site and from
what we've heard from local residents
um i think we also ought to consider the
infrastructure side of it
id1 because
it is
that people are already struggling at
the doctor's surgeries
um it's got the schooling issues and i
know there's going to be some
contribution
but whether that will meet the
requirement that's going to come from
this i'm not convinced
um and the other one that i
slightly highlighted was the id8 which
was greenways and the movement of the
footpaths and what have you
so um
that's it that's why i think i'm funny
difficult i know we've got to find a
place for all these houses we've been
given this task
to fight to locate somewhere to put all
the houses in in this district
you know 6 600 houses and it's been a
difficult task but i'm not convinced
this is the right location
i'll get you
thank you councillor song
councillor elliott
thank you chair
jeff for i've been what my colleagues
have said and i completely agree with
all of it i'm not going to reiterate
what i said about the air quality
but i will reiterate about the um the
vehicle movements backwards and forwards
killer marsh won't sustain that i drive
into killer marsh four times a week to
the surgeries i'm not entirely sure that
the doctors the dentists
and the schools
can can actually
accommodate the amount of people that
are going to move into them
so
and then again i agree with my
colleagues
thank you chad
thank you councillor elliott
councillor barker
[Music]
thank you chair
uh just uh just a comment really and uh
i'll start off by saying i have got the
full respect for for the officers and
obviously putting the
the papers together and all the
background work
uh but it's our job as a committee to
listen to the objections and check on
board what people have said locally
which we've done how long we've been at
it uh but there's been enough concerns
been raised in my head
i'm struggling to support what's in here
there's too many gaps in it from where i
can
pick out uh i've not convey since we
with some of these figures the id3 and
sp14
but if somebody else can come up with a
uh
but say a motion that captures them then
that's fine
thank you councillor barker anyone else
right so that concludes the uh
the debate so we now move on to the next
section of the meeting when
um i will open the floor for motions
councillor foster
thank you chair i'd like to propose a
motion that we reject
sorry can i interrupt you council foster
i did say to mr kirkham that he wanted
to say something before we do that oh my
apologies no it's not my mistake my
mistaking
i hear the um the comments that members
make around the around the table chair
members will need to take a view on the
application in a few minutes time i'd
just like to
reiterate in in making that decision
that members take into account
the recently adopted local plan and the
allocation of the site for
for housing in that planner i'd accept
um the note the comments made about the
numbers
but ask members to weigh very carefully
the allocation in your local plan and
your legal responsibility to take your
decision in accordance with your local
plan unless material considerations
indicate and dictate otherwise so that's
your your legal responsibility in this
instance the site is allocated in your
local plan for residential development
and so that needs to be a significant
issue in your consideration
we've just discussed at some length and
a number of technical issues and again i
note members
comments on that and you'll need to
weigh those in in the balance but i'd
just like to reiterate chair that in
terms of the console t responses that
you've had in the information before you
there is in an officer opinion
no evidence that i've heard this
afternoon that would lead me to go
against the advice of those consultees
so again you need to weigh that very
carefully in the balance and if you're
minded to refuse the application what
evidence are you placing on
any evidence information that would lead
you to conclusions to resist the
application on any of those technical
elements chair and
um just the the final point that as
officers we've set out in our advice to
members
the conditions that
we believe could control all these
elements and certainly some of the
elements that have been put forward
hedgerows for example and the design of
the houses and the roads and the
footpaths
i believe could be addressed through
your consideration of any reserve
matters application in any case you
would still retain control over those
elements so in short chair just ask
members to consider very carefully the
legal responsibility you have this
afternoon the development plan that was
adopted last november and the allocation
to cite in that and the comments that
you've received from the various
consultees and
their view on the application chair i
appreciate the opportunity to make those
points thank you
thank you mr gokum right sorry uh
councillor foster
thank you chair uh bear with me while i
work through this
uh yeah i'd like to propose that uh we
reject uh officers uh recommendations
and reject this uh proposal for uh
planning permission at this site uh for
the reasons which i've spoken about
already i've given some of the uh
uh the appropriate policies already but
i'm happy to go to him again mr kirkham
one is the first one is that it sees the
figure in the local plan
uh and also mentioning their good access
to frequent public transport services
policy
uh sdc 12
bracketed age
uh that there isn't uh good access to
public transport
uh also that we follow uh our local plan
uh number two uh the attenuation pond is
in the green belt i don't believe this
meets uh the exceptional circumstances
as in the uh set out in the local plan i
believe that's id10
uh paragraph 147 of the mppf uh
development not to be approved except in
very special circumstances that's for
the same point for the green belt
and for number three which as i said
before is more difficult but also to
reject it on grounds that are the
traffic's not sustainable as in id3
also
in the planning framework paragraph 104
b
uh and then uh and then lastly for
myself lastly anyway except we'll take
an addition to this
um also uh
uh
stc14
uh
development proposals will not be
printed unless can be demonstrated that
any land potentially affected by
contamination or instability so that
that one there that's about the uh the
mining and the mine shafts especially
the one that we don't know about
also uh council hearts one has mentioned
id1 and id8 and happily here from
council hearts on if he wants to add
those to my proposal if i'm allowed to
do that chair
yes you will
cancer also do you want to respond to
counselor foster
[Music]
yeah
yeah i mentioned uh id one
infrastructure delivery
and developer contributions
um
i'm not convinced that the plan meets
that
those requirements
um especially under these circumstances
at the moment
with the
clear problems with the doctor's
surgeries and and schooling
um
and id8
which is the public rights of way that
are going to be affected
throughout the site
and altered i understand that they're
going to be there is going to be some
movement on these but
at the end of the day they are
there is some issues raised by the uh
um i can't remember what they're called
now the
people who deal with the footpaths they
get
um
thank you you know the yeah right
rambles and days of the us yeah yeah
counselor are you willing to accept
those additions to your motion uh
absolutely chair and just before we uh
we we have a second can you be okay
yeah
just before we uh somebody hopefully
seconds that uh proposal just before and
we take a vote what i'd like to add to
it is a big concern of mine uh uh
is there is the traffic here and it's
very difficult to get around that
traffic issue absolutely and when we
look at what evidence has been put
forward from the traffic it's been
provided by uh by the developer not by
highways not by objectors not by the
parish council so what i'd like to do is
uh if this is to stand up in future
because this is not at the end of it i'm
sure if this is a stand-up in future we
need uh we need some more information so
that we can take
up for me a better view on on this
rather than just receiving uh
you know one story as regards what's
happening to the traffic we've heard
from everybody that lives there
uh how bad it is and i know myself uh
but we've heard a different story when
it came to some of the uh information we
received thank you for that chair
thank you guys of course
i'll second it
we have a second with council armitage
capsule
i was going to second chair and and
provide provide the the basis for the
contract contradicting evidence that
adrian was requesting
um we we've had we've had the the um
the environment uh cabinet member here
actually saying that the information
that nor the derbyshire county council
has provided is out of date planning law
does permit eyewitness evidence and it
does permit photographic evidence we've
got them there they prove that flooding
has taken place we can see with our own
eyes so those roads are not
sufficient to actually accommodate the
traffic there
that that would hold up before um
before an inspection should it be uh be
um to feel should it be required to do
so
um so yeah i can't second cost bills
already done it but fully support what's
been said
uh mr kirkham is just seeking some
clarity
yeah i've just um come back to the
proposal secondary just so we understand
um exactly as officers the decision that
you've had to take a vote on
um
we've mentioned
the issue about
and the number proposed exceeding the
local planned number and
there's policy lc one that i think
counselor foster mentioned in respect of
that
then there's there was the issue about
um limited access to public transport sd
c12h
and i just wondered if the the issue
regarding
sustainable travel is related to that or
is that just related to the the issue of
cumulative impact on the highway network
thank you i appreciate that yeah it did
get confusing at that point yes that is
related to uh this
the cumulative impact absolutely and the
sustainable travel was the third part
for id3
yeah so so that may be a highway issue
that's that's bundled together that's
the only point i'm just trying to
clarify chair
it can be it can be if that's if it's
the decision member state to
separate them that that i understand i
just want to be clear
i i'd like them separated so it's clear
that the effect that you know that it
affects uh that's one of the reasons
for it being 330 in the local plan
absolutely
and then there was the issue about
inappropriate development in the
greenbelt which is in relation to the
attenuation ponds and um
council foster i think mentioned id 10
um and the mppf paragraphs but there's
also the council's own policies in
respect of greenbelt
impact
um then i'm
clear on the issue of land contamination
instability chair that's sdc 14
and then the issue that
counselor i think counselor
foster made again
um maybe the council of hearts on as
well about
um not
being meeting the
mitigation that you would be looking for
that's policy id
one and then the issue about the public
rights away affected again
are you wishing those to be
put together or to be divorced
so there's those six elements chair um
and
i think i'm clear now but my
recommendation again would be that the
the final wording of that is delegated
to myself in consultation with yourself
chair do you need a moment just to
confirm with the clock about
all those adrian um can we separate
those actually
please
yes if that's the that's what the
committee wishes that would make seven
seven individual reasons yes
right
yeah i just um want to be absolutely
clear if the decision is taken review
the application we've got it absolutely
right that's that's the reason i ask so
i appreciate that thank you
well we have a motion and we have a
second um i'll announce the clerk to
read out uh the motion
yes thank you chair as i understand then
it is to um refuse
planning permission against officer
recommendations for the reasons which uh
just being iterated there which are
essentially about the density of the
development exceeding the land uh or
rather the
housing figure within the local plan and
there was the issues then about the lack
of good transport links public transport
links which already exist
um issues then about
inappropriate development within the
green belt and in particular the
attenuation tanks
increase in traffic um which makes it
not actually a sustainable development i
think that was one of the issues which
you were concerned about
um there was a also the issue about
potential uh contamination of the land
given the fact that there are issues
about the sort of mine workings which
are unknown
um there was also concerns then about
whether the infrastructure and funding
or package or amelioration would be
sufficient
and then issues also then about the
impact on public rights of way um and
generally the environment in that sense
have i captured the essence of it there
members
object
also as well as contamination
instability i think that's an
instability indeed
uh cancer foster and uh cancer armitage
is over and seconder are you happy with
that uh summary of uh the
motion in that case we'll move to the
vote which will be by roll call
right thank you chair
councillor armitage
for
councillor barker for
councillor cooper
abstain
councillor elliot
council of foster
for
hall
for
councillor hancock
for
councillor heartsaw
[Music]
councillor jones
council of powell
as chair and i will choose to abstain
and counce
oh
that was four
uh ten for chair and two abstentions uh
the motion has passed
uh
thank you um
uh we come to item six which is urgent
business i have no urgent business uh so
i can now declare that the meeting is
closed
uh thank you for your attendance and
your attention
um it's been a bit of a marathon but um
thank you for uh your courtesy
thank you
you